hello everyone and welcome to another
epic battle from this year's Tata steel
Masters Edition it is round 10 and it is
bookish versus pregnant and the game is
uh incredibly complicated and you guys
will enjoy it I imagine as those games
are the best so let's dive straight into
it uh with the white pieces opens with
Pawn to C4 he goes for the English
opening uh we have C5 going for the
symmetrical reply Knight to F3 Knight to
F6 and now Knight to C3 and Knight to C6
the Four Knights of the English we have
D4 striking in the center uh C captures
Knight captures and now Pawn the E6 so
very standard stuff here uh the
so-called anti-benoni or or the Spielman
defense with A3 Bishop to E7 and now
Pawn to E4 striking in the center uh we
have Castles by Prague and now Knight to
F3 uh retreating with the Knight this is
the main move here you you want to
retreat either the uh to F3 or you might
consider some other moves but if if you
leave the Knight here the problem is the
queen is not controlling the D5 Square
to give you an example uh let's say we
play something like Bishop D2
immediately D5 is played by black and
once you give black D5 uh black just
equalizes on the spot and there's not
much to look forward to now you have to
trade for example E capital c captures
Knight C captains Knight captures let's
say castles and black just trades
everything captures captures captures
and captures Bishop F6 and the blacks
solved all of his problems uh both
players with the bishop pair equal
material symmetrical setup uh not much
to look forward to here that's why
Knight to F3 is the the top move here
and now you don't have D5 as the D5
square is controlled four times by white
as you can see so here Queen to A5 by
Prague and now Bishop to D2 We have
Queen to H5 Shifting the queen to the
other side of the board and now while
Bishop to E2 and sometimes the bishop to
D3 are the main moves here uh gookers
goes Rook to G1
and here he makes his intentions clear
he wants to play G for a sacrifice upon
and open up lines of attack towards
Brock's King and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game so
Prague says all right your queen is no
longer guarding the five the best to
reply always the flank attack is the
strike in the center especially if the
king is still in the center of the board
so Pawn to D5 and okay yeah glucose goes
G4 probably accepts the challenge Knight
captures on G4 and C captures on D5 now
we have e captures and Knight captures
uh and here Bishop to C5 very tricky uh
move now going after the F2 pawn and it
seems like there is no way for gokash to
defend uh but there is one of course as
I mean he wouldn't just play this if he
didn't prepare it look at this queen to
E2 and now you might be thinking but uh
okay but what about Bishop captures and
F2 surely The Queen Is Not defending the
F2 pawn and it's not uh the actually the
Knight here is defending the F2 Pawn
what I mean by this is that after Bishop
captures you can play Queen captures on
F2 and after Knight captures there's
Knight F6 check winning back the queen
as the G Pawn is pinned once you move
the king Knight captures on H5 and
you're just up a full piece for example
Knight captures an E7 Knight captures on
G7 and that's pretty much it white is up
a full Bishop as you can see uh so okay
after Queen the E2 proxy is all right
that's a that's a fine move uh he plays
Pawn to F5 he wants to play F captures
on e4 and open up the f file for the
black Rook to go after that F2 Pawn uh
so Knight to F4 attacks prox queen queen
to F7 and now we have Rook to G2 a very
tricky move now uh Knight the G5 is
objectively best for for Lookers but he
doesn't like what happens after an ig5
for example Queen to B3 and now Rook
captures on G4 F captures you've uh
eliminated the one of the attackers of
the F2 pawn and now you trade Queens
Queen F4 check Queen characters Bishop
captures with checking h8 and now Knight
to F7 with check and it seems like white
is doing okay now either King to G8 and
then you have to worry about a whole lot
of discoveries or or you capture here
Bishop captures and now you try to play
this where it's equal material uh and
you know anything anything can happen
white it does have the past e-pawn
whether it's a weakness or a strength
that they would have to discuss it in
length but Google doesn't like this he
plays Rook to G2 and now Prague actually
uh has a winning or sort of close to
winning position but he has to play it
incredibly uh precisely I will just show
it to you because it's so so complicated
now the winning move or rather what proc
did not play proc played Queen to E7 uh
the winning movies F captures an E4 and
now that I've told you this you're
probably thinking uh yeah of course
that's the winning move what else would
I play but it's so complicated to
calculate everything okay you don't
capture rookie you just trapped the
queen but Knight G5 attacks the queen
and now let's say queen F5 you want to
keep an eye on your knight and attack
the White Knight and G5 Rook captures
Sanji for Queen captures and now Queen
to C4 with check uh King date you pick
up the bishop on C5 now Rook to F5 you
attack the queen and the Knight and then
G5 but now Knight to D5 and now you
can't capture on G5 because of Queen to
f8 Checkmate so here you would have to
play H6 challenge the knight uh Queen to
D6 uh and now after Rook captures on G5
Bishop captures and queen captures you
will play Queen to f8 with check and it
seems like white is making some progress
but after King to H7 uh black is
actually better here so for example
Knight to E3 uh it's uh well it's a it's
a position you can play the material is
a sort of equal black is up a pawn uh
but uh for example Queen A5 check will
make it problematic for black for white
uh to do anything with the king the king
will be stuck in the center of the board
and it it will be easier to play this
with black so that's uh how proc should
have continued but after Rook to G2 he
played Queen to E7 and now he just
allows gulkish a move that uh probably
uh Prague didn't take into consideration
or rather he did taken into
consideration uh probably the move he
didn't take into consideration comes a
bit after and we're going to discuss
this here Ponte E5 and it doesn't really
make sense it's just a pawn sacrifice
you will open lines of attack towards
the white king the problem is the white
king is not staying on E1 so here we do
have Knight C captures on E5 but now uh
is just castles Queen side and now
look at this his Bishop is coming to
this diagonal The Rook is here the
bishop can come to see for the queen can
come to C4 uh the Knight can come to G5
this is looking like uh one very
impressive attack but still it's Prague
to move here and proc plays Bishop to D6
and this makes it all the more easier
for gookish to
uh well the sort of uh show uh his
dominant possession the way you want to
play this is Knight captures and F3 and
again it's such a complicated line but
this entire game is so complicated I
will just show it Queen characters and
now look at this Pawn to B5 you go after
the the white king you cannot play Queen
captures on A8 because Bishop B7
trapping the the uh White Queen also the
bishop covers the A7 Pawn so you're
gonna have to play Queen to D5 with
check and now who knows let's a king to
h a rook D1 anything can happen you try
uh to get the queen away uh from the
defense of the rook and f8 but now let's
say queen to C7 now you actually have
Queen captures an A8 uh and now let's
say Bishop B7 it seems like the queen is
trapped now you have Knight the E6
attacking the black queen and the rook
and f8 and after Queen to C6 now you
have to part with your queen but you
play Queen captures on B7 uh removing
the defender of the C5 Bishop Queen
captures Knight captures and after Queen
to C6 it's a very very tricky position
for example King to B1 just leaves a
white uh very dominant here you you
cannot even capture the this Knight if
you capture the Knight you're just
Bishop to B4 and now you will also lose
the rook and f8 and okay you kind of do
grab two pieces for the for the Rook but
let's have three attacks the Knight
Knight F6 and now Rook C1 black just
gets destroyed let's say queen to
somewhere you're gonna or or even B it
doesn't really matter You're Gonna Play
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
you're just gonna double up rook G to C2
there's no defense against this uh I
mean it's such a complicated position uh
where either side can uh you know emerge
Victorious but Knight captures and F3
was objectively the best way to go a
proc played Bishop to D6 and now Bishop
to C3 the bishop now assumes this
beautiful diagonal uh that's a weird
Arrow again and now we have Knight
characters on F3 Queen captures and
Bishop to E6 and now uh Lucas goes Pawn
to H 3 a bit more precise is the capture
right away on E6 because in the first
you play captures captures and then H3
if you go this move order Pawn to H3 now
Prague could just play Bishop captures
on F4 with check and uh that's pretty
much it captures captures Knight F6 and
frog holds however Prague decided after
the spawn to H to remove to sacrifice a
piece he played Bishop to E5 and this is
now where things get completely crazy uh
Knight captures on E6 Queen captures an
E6 and now H captors and G4 grabbing
that piece but now Bishop captures on C3
making Queen captures impossible because
of Rook ac8 winning the White Queen but
now B captures on C3 and now Rook a to
d8 controlling the D file and preparing
Queen to A2 but now has just placed
G captures on F5 this is a brilliant
move and it really shows how difficult
it is to play this position with Prague
now you don't want to trade Queens
you're down a piece you can't play Rook
captain is because of Rook capture 78
and the problem is you cannot play Queen
to A2 you really want to play this move
here if you can play this you know that
you're never losing this game you have
full control over the D file the queen
is an A2 that white king is either
getting checkmated or you know you have
a Perpetual so yeah but there's a
problem uh the position is winning for
Lucas by force and it's a very tricky
line so feel free to pause the video and
try to solve this hypothetical line uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is a
rook captures on G7 with check I imagine
it wasn't too difficult for you to solve
this because you know you the move has
to come with Tempo uh otherwise you just
allow black to start checking you uh but
yeah congratulations to everyone who
spotted this and who calculated
everything out now King captures is met
with Queen to G3 check and the real
problem is you don't have King h8
otherwise Queen to E5 check and you get
checkmated King to Jade now look at this
beautiful sacrifice Bishop C for check
you give up the piece uh Queen captures
and The Rook the G1 with check King F7
Rook to G7 Checkmate that's only one of
your problems the other one is even if
you don't get checkmated let's say you
play something like King H6 now comes
Queen to H4 with check and you nicely
connect with the Rook on d8 and okay
it's not that black and white because
here after you capture let's say
captures captures and captures uh the
black queen will win the the bishop on
F1 21 checking the two queen captures on
F1 but the position is still objectively
winning for white because you can
control the blacking a bit too easily
for example Queen E7 tracking H6 Queen
to E3 with checking G7 Queen E5 check
and now doesn't really matter King to F7
Queen E6 checking G7 F6 comes with check
then F7 comes with check and then even
f8 comes with check forcing the king to
the to the back Rank and now you just
start gobbling up everything King G7
Queen captures with check King to G6 and
now you capture this Pawn protecting the
F2 Pawn you have two pass pawns here A
and C Pawn uh so it's three to one of
course this is completely winning for
white so very tricky and probably what
Prague was hoping for but he saw that
it's not going to go his way if he goes
Queen to A2 so he tries Rook captures on
D1 check first queen captures on D1 and
now Queen to A2 but uh now it's even
worse Bishop to D E3 and they're just no
good way to make use of this queen now
you can block checks easily we have
rooked the E8 and now Rook the G4 F6 can
be met with the G6 so uh gookish it
doesn't rush it Rook to G4 we have Queen
captures on A3 with check King to D2 and
now Queen to B2 check but just Queen to
C2 of course you cannot trade Queens uh
Queen to B6 is still hoping to to get
something out of this but now Queen to
A2 with check King to h8 and now Rook to
D for the true purpose of Rook to G4 uh
blocking the The Queen's reach of the F2
pawn and now Queen to H6 with check King
to C2 and queen to H2 again going after
the F2 Pawn but just Queen F7 now Lucas
gives up the pawn as it's pretty much
irrelevant Queen captures with check
King to B3 and now uh okay The Rook is
hanging Rook to G8 but now Bishop to C4
goes after the rook and now once The
Rook moves again now you play Queen to
East 7 new threatened checkmate with
Queen E8 or Rook d8 doesn't really
matter so H5 creating some reading room
for the black king but still Queen G5 uh
playing incredibly precise just the
strongest moves here Queen F3 guarding
H5 and now Rook to H4 and there's no
defense against Rook captures on H4 the
bishop covers G8 so that's pretty much
it one more check was given Queen D1
checking to B2 but it was in this
position on move 40 upon reaching time
control that pregnant resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here there is no check that can be given
uh Queen covers the D2 Square Bishop
covers the E2 Square so ah there there's
no way to at least harass the white king
a little bit so it's pointless to
continue Rook captures and H5 will force
black to give up the queen and then you
just get checkmated
uh so yeah very nicely played by both of
them incredibly complicated game as one
would expect from uh from uh to such
incredible prodigies they always play a
very complicated chess and they always
play very strong moves but this time
even though Prague had that one uh
window of opportunity it was who came up
on top and takes another win so although
Prague was having a spectacular first
half of the tournament now out of the
last three games he lost to uh so uh
drops a little bit but still uh here are
the standings so you can check it out
Notre back is still leading with seven
points without a single loss followed by
Anish with six and a half points uh
absolutely like I said absolutely
incredible Anish defeated uh both Ding
and Magnus uh and uh he's still behind
Northern back so that's how strong
strong another back is uh Magnus after
losing those two games he won three
games and now he's back to third place
sharing third place with Wesley so then
in fifth place level narunyan and
Fabiano caruana in seventh rehab rapport
uh or then we have pregnant
and uh in uh sharing last place Arjun
erigasi and Vincent kymer two incredible
players who are just not having the uh
the greatest tournament uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
sorry for a bit of a longer analysis but
the lines were absolutely stunning and
uh well it's no wonder yeah you know
they miss a few of them uh so yeah
that's the game once again hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Rob
Victor David uh Patrick uh John Noonan
and Russell Scott for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular tournament uh until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day